a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
on thursday president donald trump
released that video
acknowledging for the first time that a
new administration will take over on
january 20th
serving as your president has been the
honor of my lifetime
and to all of my wonderful supporters i
know you are disappointed
but i also want you to know that our
incredible journey
is only just beginning the video comes
after his supporters stormed the u.s
capitol on wednesday
following a rally he held earlier in the
day where he encouraged the crowd to hit
up the capitol
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them lawmakers called for the
25th
amendment to be invoked which would
remove trump from
office and now hollywood is weighing in
you change the world by sharing your
stories with other people and sharing
your knowledge and wisdom of what you've
learned
on thursday lady gaga hit up twitter to
push for congress to impeach the
president
instead writing quote i hope we focus to
impeach trump so
congress has the constitutional
authority to possibly disqualify him
from future election
the 25th amendment doesn't disqualify
him he incited domestic terror
how much more violence needs to happen
this
is terrorism and john cryer summed it
all up
writing impeach him remove him arrest
him
try him and while crier and gaga are
calling for impeachment
sophia bush tweeted it feels like a
great time for the 25th amendment
stevie wonder echoed that writing in
part quote
that man is no longer able to serve as
president
because he can't accept defeat can we
afford two more weeks
i say no as for that speech trump gave
but now tempers must be cooled and calm
restored we must get on with the
business of america
my campaign vigorously pursued every
legal avenue
to contest the election results
megan mccain had something to say about
that tweeting quote
all you had to do to get trump to
concede was cancel his twitter account
for 12 hours
yeah not only did twitter remove a
handful of tweets by the president
but on wednesday they blocked him from
posting for 12 hours
then on thursday facebook announced that
it was banning trump until
at least january 20th which is of course
the end of his presidential term
[Music]
you